thank you they see Boston and then all
of a sudden like Chaka Khan is seeing
the national anthem we go [ __ ] right
there Chaka Khan you're not gonna get
that in Sacramento you know but San
Francisco is great but it's you know
it's real expensive now you know City
there's that element there you know
which is like which is different
[Music]
we're here [ __ ] uncle Joey's back
pre Church Wednesday the 14th slinging
dick and giving our mummies [ __ ] if
you're under 18 hang up now we're doing
bong hits with explosives we got
everything in this thing I want to say a
[ __ ] up off-color joke well I can't
right now where's Kathy Griffin that
[ __ ] [ __ ] Kathy Griffin uncle
Joey's here that's why you don't show up
with a head the only head I got is on my
[ __ ] helmet and it's got one eye and
it's got some nut plasma and if you're
ready if you're thirsty and I'm saying
yum Yum's for a week [ __ ] uncle
Joey's here we got a great [ __ ]
Church for you tonight get that bomb get
the cocktails get the heroin it's going
down deep tonight Leigh's gonna make up
the 1,400 he owes us and [ __ ]
milligrams tonight so get ready to
[ __ ] send flowers to a hospital it's
over [ __ ]
he ain't gonna see this we're gonna take
him right in the st. joe´s cuz see this
won't take me and got the right sugar
[Music]
can even spray for Cedars
I spring it foot just dropping you off
and emerges like you've been shot just
throw you out of the car
kick you out there like the kid in
[ __ ] traffic when they old heed those
little [ __ ] in traffic they kill all day
and [ __ ] they just drew them in front of
mergency say [ __ ] we got two
tremendous reads tonight
we got [ __ ] primo OG three Mexicans
and one I grew this and [ __ ] classic
OG this is going back get over it let's
do a bond it don't worry about what they
should [ __ ]
it's time to make you sweat well like
that what's that band in the ATCC Music
Factory yeah that's us the CC Music
Factory we're gonna make you sweat we're
gonna make you jump up and down Lee's
got a whole new outlook on bong hits
it's how you look at the bong they
understand if you look at the bong it my
trouble to necessarily give you trouble
if you look at the bong Dilla's very
gets Kasane then it's very good I say
maybe laissez-faire attitude look at me
drop in the fried shine you
[ __ ] tonight
here you go there Frenchie here we go
yeah Pepe LePew Jimmy pebbles they is
let's go to me premise everywhere I look
I see your eyes there ain't a woman that
comes we gonna [ __ ] you over here
in the trap of death there you go there
you go that's the one that killed Louie
that's the one that killed Kennedy go
ahead that's the one that's grandpa oh
yeah we're starting early tonight
[ __ ] these bong of this weed is
[ __ ] up tonight
start my eyes are not you don't need to
start yet the second play of that today
tonight's the buffet of debt you
understand me how long sound like a
[ __ ] squeaky toy in my mouth like the
dog in [ __ ] snatch I told you we're
gonna make you sweat like the CC Music
Factory
[Music]
I love to call it drive it [ __ ] anyone
write to the king
you know me thunk I'm half [ __ ] I'm
not gonna tell you I'm a Phi Beta Kappa
what I'm not we're gonna do understand
so much you make a profit
some months you lose money you know
saying this month a gotta lose money
it's working hey thugs sometimes you
slip in at the garage door my friend
Roger Holloway drove drove through the
garage door wait I forgot to pull a
[ __ ] it's talking to this [ __ ]
jamoke and I [ __ ] lost my
concentration
[Music]
you [ __ ] if the cops come here
TIG gasps make it suck my dick you
understand me we got our own [ __ ]
tear gas here at the Voodoo Lounge [ __ ]
you think you're [ __ ] with
[ __ ] you think I'm gonna show up
here and half a [ __ ]
not in a million [ __ ] years my mother
didn't come in a raft from Cuba
for me to be [ __ ] around with you
[ __ ] are you ready for the second
bucket the first one was primo
this is classic this is a tremendous
weed groped by the one I jus let's take
my training and crush it up more so it's
final for you soon good to keep bridges
here we go Keith he ain't stopping
he ain't stopping listen to this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
I said hey
[Music]
he has a stop Keith Richards is not
stopping two [ __ ] minutes
[Applause]
Eagle
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] looking good and guess
what's coming guess who's at the door
knock knock who's there death death who
[ __ ] you you die until I [ __ ]
we still got it
san lazaro throws you a little blessing
back you know I'm saying let's do this
we put squall
oh [ __ ]
it's only rock and roll but I like you
don't say
[Music]
Oh hold on that's the one that's the one
that's the one that killed Chris Cornell
let's go suck that it
that's a savage right
[Music]
training makes perfect in the stamping
how good was that fun
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
people [ __ ] around
tonight we got one of my childhood
friends coming in to talk about North
Bergen all the benefits of growing up
there and here's to you a 3-star [ __ ]
bonus he's still coughing but it is
[Music]
knife in my heart right on the stage oh
[ __ ]
tremendous tonight let's match the
champions he's still going over there
[ __ ]
[Music]
I told you we shown a big delay
he was a prince of darkness he always is
Tommy pockets [ __ ]
now we do it here at the Voodoo Lounge
all we need is you we're gonna have a
raffle next block come to the booth
allowance for one night and if you can
make it you stay here tonight how you
doing partner
ready put them you got spots
oh yeah the spots are out they got no
color in his basement
[Applause]
[Music]
see
[Music]
I need three ones if you got along when
you check off the box on your license
but next to it from my uncle lease I add
just goes my lung goes right to leads I
need it after that you if another bong
hit
you're done for them you said no they
rock and roll but I like it what God
suckers it's only rock you gotta be free
tonight it's Wednesday
tomorrow's Thursday you're almost over
we added new tickets for the Ice House
if you end up going on come on by we
will be there stars
turning purple you know survive tonight
I got an investment iam saying you ain't
going nowhere unless you get that half a
mil under the bed you ain't dying till
the last dollars gone
that's what Julie Jews don't die to the
last pennies gun [ __ ] leave it to the
kids [ __ ] those little SAP suckers let
them go and steal like we did for 20
years [ __ ]
[Music]
little funky people think you're dealing
we think you're tuned into [ __ ] The
Big Bang Theory
suck my dick that's a Big Bang Theory
this is the Big Bang Theory over here
what we're doing tonight be the end or
you're out [ __ ]
that's the name of one new show The Big
Bang Theory how's that one for you
there's smoke everywhere even the
[ __ ] Pope is on fire you understand
me one more layer you done lease over
this city he's thinking about going back
to his Elling job he can't take he's
doing the math of his head Oh oh [ __ ]
they got mold on him I already ate one
tremendous he's got [ __ ] mold mother
that's when you know you got a good
start and these got mold on them too
you're lucky tonight Joe my friend said
in Jersey Bobby been the found one with
mold on it he clean the mold walls and
he'd only Jersey people do that shake
this at the end of the week who gives a
[ __ ] it's been [ __ ] beautiful in here
what hot air conditioners always on so
you're out of the bushes tonight he's
not to eat no edibles I ain't a [ __ ]
conglomeration of mouldy edibles from
the edibles my fungi so is gonna make a
comeback I'm seeing purple dragon [ __ ]
you gotta take a chance Columbus did you
know I'm saying 20 years ago we breathe
in those molds who gives a [ __ ] just a
little something for the [ __ ] nut the
immune system can test the immune system
from time to time
what's mold yogurt rates the same
[ __ ] thing yogurt cheese we need some
of these [ __ ] the same thing right
hippies mold cheese and [ __ ] on the
same give eat somebody's [ __ ] nothing
it tastes a little funny your mouth for
a couple of hours then you pop a tic tac
in your back you'll say you'll kiss your
mom she don't know nothing
she don't know nothing [ __ ] leave
one more since we got no other class we
got no edibles
unless you wanna watch you can finally
forget drill
[Music]
that's it and that's that do not forget
next Friday and Saturday
not this Friday and sadly next Friday
and Saturday governor's might be town
Long Island for shows no Thursday don't
come crying to me later Joey we were
gonna buy tickets when we forgot don't
come crying to me I'm telling you right
now
one more bondage for the spirits and
we'll get this podcast on the right time
suckers you know I love you I'm happy
you joined us tonight please still over
there thinking about quitting we sitting
there gonna leave this in my life no
more I'm up till 4:00 in the morning my
wife wakes me up on the couch
[Music]
reality back to reality show
[Music]
what do you think of that [ __ ]
that's a blood that's a cloud right
there you want to come to the Voodoo
Lounge you got a boat clouds like that
on a daily you understand me beside that
now I'm tip-top Magoo I'm ready to
[ __ ] go youtube.com slash see these
last Joey Diaz that's the place to be
[ __ ]
ten minutes don't forget to [ __ ] and use
cushion hello douchey and wash that
rotten [ __ ] you don't say
you've been walking around with that
dirty snatch for a week now it's time to
fumigate that [ __ ] the weekends
coming who loves you more than me
concepts I'll see you in ten minutes
youtube.com / see it's last showing this
is the place to be [ __ ] stay
black